also nehmen wir darf ich jetzt begrüßen
ist ja kein logo den ski ass
europaabgeordneter der grünen und ein
enger freund von herrn navalny sie waren
zusammen studieren sie haben zusammen
studiert sie beobachten und begleiten
diese dramatischen situation jetzt auch
hier vor der charité wie bewerten sie
die situation jetzt auch was die
politischen ausmaße handeln
das ist in der tat sehr dramatisch das
ist eine humanitäre katastrophe wenn man
das so sehen möchte aber das ist
natürlich auch eine politische
katastrophe denn wir sind zeugen von
noch einem anschlag auf einen
oppositionellen in russland und zwar
einem der wichtigsten einer der
wichtigsten figuren der
oppositionsbewegung und das ist schon
das dritte mal dass alexei navalny
tätlich angegriffen wird auf diese art
und weise was hat das für eine bedeutung
dass er jetzt ausgerechnet nach
deutschland kommt das ist sehr brisant
die thematik ist äußerst sensibel man
weiß nicht wie sein gesundheitszustand
ist was bedeutet das es bedeutet dass
deutschland natürlich auch eine
mitverantwortung übernimmt für die
aufklärung der situation natürlich steht
jetzt im vordergrund das leben retten ja
und auch die gesundheitlichen
folgeschäden im rahmen zu halten
aber es wird auch darum gehen und das
haben ja auch gesehen viel technik autos
messtechnik und so weiter die da sind
nach spuren zu suchen und nach beweisen
zu suchen um zu verstehen was das für
den anschlag war auch um medizinischen
erfolg zu sichern
aber eben auch die politische
verantwortung aufzuklären und dann wird
es darum gehen will können wir das zu
rechnen dass wir sind sehr schwierige
politische fragen deutschland ist jetzt
mit im boot
wir müssen uns natürlich alle an fakten
halten die sind wenig bekannt natürlich
das ist alles sehr spekulativ ob es ein
anschlag war ob es wirklich eine
vergiftung war alles deutet natürlich
darauf hin
sie haben es gerade angesprochen
wenn es wirklich ein anschlag war welche
dimension hat das dann das ist offen
gehen gegen oppositionelle geht und
welchen auftrag hat dann zum beispiel
auch deutschland oder die europäische
gemeinschaft um vielleicht auch druck
aufzubauen so etwas vielleicht in
zukunft verhindern zu können
das was wir erleben ist ein symptom ein
symptom das wir kennen wir kennen
litvinenko wir kennen viele anderen
fälle wo eben anschläge geübt worden
sind und die werden höchstwahrscheinlich
putin oder putins umgebung zu gerechnet
insofern ist das wenn man es jetzt ganz
pragmatisch sieht nichts neues aber das
bedeutet und das bestätigt unsere
position von der eu aber auch von vielen
verschiedenen auch von meiner partei zum
beispiel dass wir gegenüber den putin
regime nicht zu weich auftreten sollen
natürlich pragmatisch und realpolitisch
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass das
ein system ist das menschenleben kostet
und menschen freiheit kostet und das
sehen wir jetzt hier und das bestätigt
das noch mal
welche brisanz hat das jetzt auch vor
dem hintergrund der krise in
weißrussland da hat sich im moment eine
gemengen lage zusammengebraut
die politisch äußerst sensibel und auch
vorsichtig behandelt werden muss was
bedeutet es auch für unsere regierung in
deutschland welches fingerspitzengefühl
muss man da haben um noch nicht noch
mehr zu zerschlagen oder in die alten
fußstapfen des kalten krieges zu stoßen
es ist sehr schwierig nicht denn die
alten fußstapfen des kalten krieges zu
stoßen wenn die andere seite sage ich
mal jetzt oder die russische regierung
das immer wieder selber reproduziert na
also diese bilder hätten wir in den
achtzigern erwartet aber nicht anfang
dieses jahrtausends was klar ist aber
das ist auch eine erinnerung an uns im
vergleich zu lukaschenko putin plötzlich
nicht mehr als tyrannen aus ja nicht
mehr als autoritärer aus und wir haben
ja gesucht nach einer möglichkeit putins
unterstützung bei der lösung des anderen
konflikts
zu finden zu recht weil ohne russland
werden wir wahrscheinlich auch die
situation in weißrussland wie wir das
früher genannt haben in belarus klären
aber es muss uns klar dabei sein dass
die natur des systems putin nicht viel
anders und nicht viel besser ist
dankeschön lowinski klare worte zur
aktuellen politischen position und
situation vor allen dingen und man sieht
wie brisant das ganze ist und das wird
politisch natürlich noch eine eine hohe
diskussions grad haben in der zukunft